if you had to would you rather your mom
or your dad
if you had to answer it if you really
had to oh my God
welcome back to another amazing episode
of careful boys today we have Jesse mom
hard-hitting question of the day how
would things be different if your
partner was the same ethnicity as you
oh I think I would hate it yeah I'll
tell you something I don't know I
wouldn't know because I never uh had a
serious relationship with a Japanese
girl Why didn't it was you're against it
no Kimiko no uh no problem no proximity
you never had Japanese people around you
that they're ugly
[Laughter]
nah just kidding I did okay remember and
uh the school we went to in junior high
right yeah there's tons of Jeff there
was a girl I was like had a question she
liked me back right and then right when
you know we were starting to talk or
whatever she was so [__] shy that her
friends would do the whole pushing her
to come talk to me and then she would
just run away as soon as we're like
[__] right about one feet away she
would run away and I and I had a Mac she
was very pretty I wanted to talk to her
and then I got kicked out of that Junior
High so I didn't lost lost love right
there yeah there it is sometimes I think
about her so that's the closest it could
have been well no that was yeah that was
the closest
time I dated a Japanese girl what do you
think a marriage would be like if you
were in a Japanese marriage like you and
her 100 Japanese well I mean it's hard
to determine personality but I bet that
culturally it would be so much easier
because they could I'm assuming she can
speak Japanese right because there are a
lot of Japanese Americans that can't
[__] speak Japanese but I'm assuming
the one that I get with is can speak so
they can talk to my parents even though
my parents can speak English they're
it's not that good so then they could
have a more meaningful relationship
deeper conversations
um
we could probably continue
teaching our kids Japanese if we get
married and stuff like that too and then
so culturally it might be easier there's
just a lot of things that are just
unspoken and it's just like it's there
yeah there's just things that you don't
have to like teach each other you know
yeah take your shoes off and freaking of
the house yeah that is true I feel like
that that Dynamic makes me uncomfortable
because it's too familiar it's too close
it makes you feel paternal it makes you
feel like this is like a family member
which I know is incorrect for me it's
kind of it was like I think that's why I
actually never dated my exact ethnicity
and culture because it didn't feel
interesting I think because of that but
now being almost 40 I'm like I could
totally see if I were to marry though it
does make things way smoother and easier
yeah because it's like we're on the same
page like almost 50 already now the
other 50 is just your personality versus
like oh we gotta get on the same page
starting at zero and build like
everything because like culturally like
we already know like
um you know like some some Asians they
bow or some do whatever or something you
have to hold with two hands or like
there's like all these things all right
right I actually think it'll be harder
for me if she was from Japan harder what
about Japanese American like that would
be the same culture because I don't
consider them the same culture so it
would like it'll be like dating my
parents because like it'll be so like
it'll be you know what I mean yeah
yeah that's like dream right because
that there's a there'll be a culture
Clash there yeah because there's a
there's an American aspect to it that
they're not used to that is true yeah
but I do think
in general it should be easier because
there are like just in in the
Multicultural relationships that there's
like there's more there's more things
you have to kind of discuss in friction
because
um just the way you do [__] is so
different and they'll be called they'll
be culture shocked but what I do like
about my relationship now because we're
interracial
it almost creates like this [__]
filter like force field because like my
parents to me I felt like were really
toxic and if my relationship if my wife
was exactly my ethnicity there's no
stopping that that's being passed on
they're gonna talk to talk to her the
way they talk to me they're gonna demand
the same things like like give me your
[__] keys to your car in your house
or whatever like I own your or my
property too because you're an extension
of my son oh yeah because they can't
communicate to her there's like a
[__] thing and then on the flip side
Geo's family is not toxic but what's
cool is because I'm uh something else
there was almost like a [__]
Pocahontas John Smith like we had to
like like earn each other's like Rapport
every single step of the way you know
like you want food I I play music yeah
food music and then we were like you
know we kind of you want King Taco
slowly built it from from scratch yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know versus like if I
met like like a Taiwanese parents like
oh I'm bored I like to do whatever I
don't care you go to Harvard you know
like no I didn't go to Harvard oh oh get
out of here yeah yeah
what do you think about that there is
the Foreigner pass because then when
your parents are like oh [__] I don't
know this culture they're on their best
behavior and they have to really get to
know you for you and you get to know
them for them rather than all these like
true screening through the the culture
yeah yeah because when they're too
comfortable then they know the script
yeah and they can judge you or whatever
but they're they're if it's a brand new
culture they're probably nervous about
if they're breaking any cultural rules
you know did you ever date a Korean guy
I didn't never oh well because
of like kind of similar to what you were
saying like my parents don't have a
healthy relationship and we didn't have
like a healthy family Growing Up So my
worst nightmare is marrying my dad and
becoming my mom
a lot of those like very stereotypical
toxic Korean man traits I'm like oh yeah
never never what are some of the top
three violent
rage filled [__] that's true
I've seen it damn yeah so you've never
even been attracted no whoa that's
remarkable and then like if you had like
a Korean I don't even like BTS I'm not
even like physically attracted you know
like this I do but like not like those
guys but if you brought like a Korean
boyfriend home like it was just there's
no like force field right it'd be like
your parents would just
my mind totally slipped that whole thing
that you painted like yeah my parents
would talk to if I had a Filipino wife
or girlfriend they would speak to her
with familiarity that because even my so
my mom is like very like
she thinks she's gentle and she's like
very nice and she goes with everything
but her her judgment and her like ideals
are very like strong so uh I remember it
being in college like all of my friends
were over in the living room and they're
just like we're just all watching TV
been hanging out for a few hours so you
know just chilling and then my mom
expects like if an elder walks in the
room everyone stands up yeah like that's
what she expects you know so she comes
in and because everyone's Asian like
she's like this
and I'm like oh sure and then she was
like tell me like I
[Laughter]
think
the lectures like refugees or something
and then like I'm like no we're [__]
American watching TV God damn it you
know it's like and that's already like
so if my wife could speak Chinese yeah
and she could directly communicate in
Chinese yeah but that's some real
toxicity but yeah that's what's funny to
me because like when people see Asians
dating Asians right they go like oh that
they're dating their own kind but in
reality to me
going outside of Japanese is already
interracial or like mixed relationship
because there's
to I didn't even I don't know it's it's
hard to like it's like it's not even
common in Asia to be dating
cross country yeah absolutely so like
that's already a big deal so then going
beyond that and then like dating black
white Mexican whatever right to me
that's not that different from dating a
Vietnamese because the language is
different the religion is different
there's so the only thing that might
ties together is like certain things
like Confucianism and the philosophy
might be same so there's like that
unspoken rule that maybe within the
Asian Community it's yeah it's gonna be
closer than dating someone who's like
Spanish or whatever right but still it
it doesn't feel as homey it still feels
foreign so then
but maybe it's because in the in the U.S
it's like there's so many generations of
like white or black or whatever that
they don't really see that difference in
in and they just see Asian as Asian even
in Chinese is like that so my mom's
Taiwanese and my dad's Cantonese and the
way my mom views my dad it's like
[Laughter]
they're like polite Asian way you know
how about for you having a Filipino wife
uh it so if she was white yeah I mean I
never you know I don't know because it's
like
she's halfway there she's halfway there
but she doesn't look it so it's like I
guess I'd be more sexually attracted to
her if she was white
because then it would it reminds me more
of my sister
it's more culturally appropriate yeah
yeah
so that would help you did kind of you
did kind of go against your culture
though by not marrying your your family
member I know tell me about it so we'll
see what happens he's so defiant dude
good job for Breaking the Chain
he didn't want to do it but he had to do
it that's why my family didn't show up
at the wedding I know but Nikki is more
is she more culturally Filipino or
culturally her family is the most
Americanized like group of Filipinos
like I've ever met like they're they had
the [__] American flag outside
because the dad was in the Navy right
and so it's just like everybody came
here and assimilated Nikki's Grandma was
very much like I want the kids to learn
English so that they they get integrated
really easily and you know it's just
very much like that and she was
basically when I first met her I
couldn't understand [__] words she
was saying like Nikki's Grandma
um total Filipino grandma like who came
here from the Philippines right uh but
then like as time went on I can now
completely understand her but like it
took [__] a decade bro or took like
Pro I probably got it like around six
years now like you could actually
understand the words or you could
understand what she's trying to
communicate I couldn't understand like
even she was in my [__] ear
L like right I'm like I don't even know
what she said there's like ah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm just like yeah yeah yeah
she could be saying like your ancestors
are [__] [__] [__] oh I hope I
hope that you guys can have a caterer if
you do he's [__] or something right
I'm like that's so sick oh my God
6666666 I like you a lot yay except me
that's literally how it was for a while
um but now it's different so but then
she's also just got Alzheimer's so it
sucks because I just got done talking
with her and yeah it's on the way out
geez yeah maybe she always did you just
didn't realize I would have no idea like
genuinely no clue she never did what
about for Tiff
you like I mean she's Salvadorian right
and the Jew I think did you date anyone
for your short freshman year
that was it
this one girl I was talking to for a
little bit like before I started into if
she was uh she was also
Salvadorian but she was like half
Persian oh that's it that sounds highly
exotic it was weird nice um I hated it
okay I didn't like the mix I'm just
kidding um but yeah I know I didn't
really grow up around a lot of like
East Asian girls East Asian American
girl it's like there wasn't really
would you culturally be technically uh
Singaporean Chinese I don't even know
what that would be honestly really if
I'm being real or Taiwanese well what
your your Dad's because when my dad
immigrated here he assimilated really
quickly because he he came here when he
was like nine or ten oh okay yeah and um
he was getting bullied a lot so he just
like when people talk to him on the
phone they think he's either white dude
or a black guy on the phone like he's
just like he's like what about when you
guys eat as a family he's like Elders
gotta get the food first or like do you
have any of those we're like a it's so
inconsistent across the board like so
much of what we do is very American so
much what we do is like very Chinese but
like it's there's no consistency there's
no like
every Chinese New Year is different like
you know okay like it's all kind of
freestyle okay it's all freestyle well
it's like well usually for a while we go
to our grandmas right and then as we got
older and as things changed we're all
like scattered we don't really do stuff
it's just kind of like it's it's more of
an afterthought than than some Chinese
you gotta stick to this tradition yeah
you know what I mean like so
everything's all over the place so it's
kind of our own rules
so with that
man like I think no matter what kind of
girl I would date
that's not like how we grew up it would
be completely different and I think no
matter what I think I am drawn to the
the difference in cultures because I do
like learning about other people's
cultures I love training like you know
just just shooting the [__] about it so
on Tiff's side does do they practice
like cultural things a lot stronger than
you guys do definitely yeah yeah like
and then you're drawn to that yeah that
was a change like having what do they do
they paint the skulls during Mexican
Halloween
but like for instance like how they
gather with family is so different than
How We Gather a family right everyone's
drunk yeah and they have like well they
do like every [__] weekend like the
the frequency of how they would get
together and hang out I was like this is
tight like you guys do this all the time
all right cool like and and just
um how they communicate with each other
how it's like like you know Chinese
people are like hella critical and
everything you know like when I go hang
with their family
it's just like not much judgment you
know what I mean that's hard to imagine
and yeah no and that was like weird for
me and I it took me years to figure out
like I I I don't know why I like hanging
with your family so much they're just so
chill and then now that you and then I
hang on my family a little bit
and then like ever sometimes every
there's always talking [__] about
something and I'm like all right bro and
then you realize like oh yeah that's
what it was right you know but um I
don't think it'd be
yeah I don't know if it would be
different could you even imagine I
couldn't even imagine yeah like if I
dated like what kind of what Joe said
like if he dated someone that was from
Japan or if I dated someone that was
East Asian American or if it was just
the same as you like same style
upbringing same style family just times
two now of course I think it would be
easier to like communicate certain
things like there are certain
but someone that celebrated Chinese New
Year like every other year yeah or just
certain unspoken things that I don't
even think about like sometimes I'm like
why is that weird for me to explain this
to you and then like for instance like
certain family gatherings like how we
gather certain rules like unspoken rules
that I wouldn't have to explain but then
again it's like it's not that big of a
deal at the end of the day like it isn't
big of a deal it could make things
easier but it's just like all right you
got to work through it anyway regardless
you guys are like that's how I kind of
see it right like I'm already with this
lady with my wife so it's like we did we
figure out how to deal with this or we
just complain about it yeah like one
thing I've had to explain to smack a lot
was that when um Filipino parents are
giving you stuff like for some reason
anytime we see my parents they just have
craploads of just stuff and they're just
like take this take this and in the
beginning like smack and be like oh it's
okay I don't need like the polite thing
would be oh no no it's okay but that's
actually not polite yeah the polite
thing is to take everything and act like
that's exactly what you needed for real
whoa like growing up right like kids my
mom would always like be mad about like
having to serve other people at the
house like like at least it was more
about how she didn't like my dad
so in my head growing up
coming over yeah going to other people's
houses and them offering you food you
always say no because you don't want to
be a burden right like so that was in my
head yeah but then I go to Tiff's
family's house oh that's bad and then
they're like hey eat some food I'm like
no it's okay it's okay but then they're
gonna go oh
yeah I think in my head and it's you
know all the way around yeah exactly
with um with your boyfriend's like
Colombian families or anything like
super different they're very
Americanized oh okay yeah what would you
what would a Colombian American family
like be like it's just straight up like
a regular American family they should
look cooler yeah
just talk about sports all day or
something stuff like that no well his
stepdad's White
Sports yeah
that Tucker Carlson you know they say
something like that just like like
normal things they're not very cultural
oh it's you just mentioned that he's
adopted
look because I heard adopted I was like
oh so he's culturally Colombian or like
ethnically Colombian but he's
Americanized because his parents adopted
him but it's not what I heard right okay
well that's like what happened to me
because like I got you know they do the
warning thing when you're coming into
the family like oh wait do you see the
Filipino side and I'm like
backyard barbecues are [__] crazy
guys
you guys are blowing my [__] mind
over here dude
placement
egg rolls
it's all potato chips too so it's like
but that's also another cool thing about
dating like or just being with you know
someone that's of a different culture
you kind of see how many [__]
similarities there are too and I think
that class probably entice people way
closer yeah so culture and ethnicity
because like there are a lot of Asian
kids that grew up hella wealthy that I
just don't have any common things and
even the way they operate like they
[__] piss me off but like there's a
lot of uh people out there that group
exactly like me and then they're you
know why black whatever and then we're
like some of the closest friends because
we just have so many of those shared
memories and like if you grew up eating
a [__] square ass pizza for lunch at
school and you know what you know what
I'm talking about like you have those
similar memories of everything like yeah
there's and then yeah you share that
space together and I think that that
that isn't spoken of enough because you
know yeah classes kind of the easier way
to unite with people for sure but I
think like Vibes and personality types
right like so like I met um Hannah's
family and then her brother and dad are
similar to me and how I think and then
her two little brothers are similar to
my nephews that we live with in Hawaii
yeah and then so for her she felt like
home and my dad and I'm dynamic because
it's so close to The Vibes of her family
right right and her her parents are as
chill as my parents you know they don't
really fuss about a lot of things and
and I mean they were both cool with us
not having a wedding or buying rings and
doing a lot of formal [__] and when they
met it was chill and I think those the
only difference was the language barrier
so I think like that's really important
too is like your your your your
immediate homes Vibe and upbringing and
like how familiar that is with the
partner and it's kind of Freudian right
because it's like oh you want to [__]
your parents but if you have someone who
reminds you of your family and that
Dynamic is there it makes sense yeah
yeah it will gravitate towards what they
know yeah what feels familiar for sure
you want to [__] your dad yep hardcore
would you eat it I am gravitating to
what I know if you had to would you
rather [__] your mom or your dad
if you had to answer it if you really
had to
oh my God
a very tough question but it's a toughie
we know it's tough but we ask
hard-hitting questions here we're not
afraid to pull any punches what about
you your sister well that's my number
one that's my dream
that's my dreams